(dramatic music)
- In Kherson, Russian forces
that occupied the city left months ago
but they're still active just
on the other side of the river behind me.
The fighting, blackouts
and food shortages have
pushed many people to leave
and for the ones who have
stayed, uncertainty remains
as the country prepares
for fighting to intensify
ahead of what Ukrainians expect
will be a major Russian
offensive in the spring.
(Tetiana speaking in foreign language)
- So one year after the war started,
we came to Kherson to see what's next
along the front lines in Ukraine.
Kherson, which was largely spared damage
during the occupation
has now become a combat zone.
Ukrainian forces have taken up positions
inside the city where there's more cover
from incoming fire and
are launching artillery
at the Russians across the river.
The Russians are shooting back
and the sound of shells
is now constant here.
(booming sound)
Ukrainian forces deny
firing from within the city.
(Dmytro speaking in foreign language)
- [Ian] We've heard the sound
of outgoing artillery fire
in central Kherson during
multiple reporting trips.
(booming sound)
The fighting is unlikely
to stop anytime soon.
Ukrainian forces have
remissions onto the far side
of the river, but
reclaiming the huge swath
of territory that Russians
still control on the far bank
is a tall order.
Bosman is a Ukrainian soldier
in the trenches near the Dnieper river.
(solider speaking in foreign language)
- Though Kherson is not a strategic hub,
it is symbolically important for Moscow.
It was the only regional capital
Russia captured last year.
So it was central to any
claims the Kremlin made
that the war had been a success.
But there was fierce resistance here
from the first days of the occupation.
(crowd speaking in foreign language)
(gunfire sounding)
- [Ian] Tetiana Kurilenko was one
of the Kherson residents
who took to the streets.
(Tetiana speaking in foreign language)
- [Ian] Despite the protests,
Moscow took steps to turn Kherson
into a Russian city.
(Tetiana speaking in foreign language)
- Now a Ukrainian flag again flies
over the regional government building
in this square where thousands
of people greeted Ukrainian soldiers.
(crowd cheering)
Many have fled since
those triumphant scenes.
Today central Kherson is a
ghost town and bears scars
from Russian artillery fire
over the last few months.
(dramatic music)
At Tropinykh Hospital in central Kherson,
only a skeleton staff remains.
But doctors say there's
enough medicine and workers
for the hospital to function.
(Leonid speaking in foreign language)
- [Ian] Doctors are also
facing other challenges,
including treating patients with injuries
from Russian artillery.
(Leonid speaking in foreign language)
- So after a year of war,
residents of Kherson are
still unsure what lies ahead.
Many have relatives on the
other side of the river
in occupied territory and have no idea
when they might see them again.
On the ground, neither Russia nor Ukraine
has achieved a major breakthrough
since Kherson was liberated last year.
(gun booming)
For now, fighting is concentrated
in Ukraine's east where a costly battle
of attrition could shape the war to come
with Russia using its manpower advantage
to slowly claw back territory.
Ukraine is pushing
Western allies for weapons
that would help them retake
territory this spring.
And any negotiations to
end the war still appear
to be a long way off.
For the people who remain in Kherson,
they know that even if Ukraine
makes progress in the war,
rebuilding will take years.
(pensive music)